pas eu de violences hier oui quand il
n'y avait pas eu de cassure il ya eu des
casseurs mais ils ont été mis hors
d'état de nuire par la police plus
rapidement que dans des manifestations
des gilet jaune voir maintenant si vous
le voulez bien s'intéresser à ce dossier
mais d'un point de vue politique vous le
savez le parti socialiste la france
insoumise mais aussi le rassemblement
national soutient le mouvement social en
cours
jean luc mélenchon le président de la
france a soumise sans nez afrique et la
précision des je crois que c'est pas le
titre exact parce que c'est un c'est un
mouvement très particulier bref le chef
le leader le lider maximo de la france
soumise et tête hier à marseille
et lui il s'est vraiment réjoui du
soutien de marine le pen mouvement dans
des termes qui ne sont pas passés
inaperçus réécouter nous ça voulait même
madame le pen je sais pas si vous êtes
au courant mais elle dit qu'il faut
manifester alors et écoutez c'est un
grand progrès d'habitude et passe son
temps à chercher plus aux arabes et aux
musulmans et pour une fois elle a
compris que quelle que soit sa religion
de sa couleur de peau on a tous des
intérêts communs et qu'on est semblable
et que à partir de 60 ans et plus tout
le monde est fatigué donc que ça vaut la
peine que les gens s'arrêtent
elle est en train de faire un progrès en
quelque sorte en direction de
l'humanisme vais quand même pas me
plaindre de ça et quant à ses adhérents
sur le tir en bas ils sont les bienvenus
maxime desgagnés dans cette émission n'a
pas forcément le goût immodéré des
petites phrases politiques mais là on
s'est dit peut-être que c'est important
ce qu'a dit jean luc mélenchon quand il
dit marine le pen est en train de faire
un progrès en direction de l'humanisme
est ce que vous croyez qu'on
surinterprète le propos j'espère qu'on
ne sera interprète
parce que effectivement on n'est pas là
pour donner des bons des mauvais points
et des bons plans en l'occurrence à
marine le pen le front national le front
national ça reste le parti anti sociale
et donc je regrette
sa prise de position j'ai compris
qu'elle était contestée d'ailleurs dans
ses propres rangs et ce qu'il a dit de
manière ironique ou pas à limite c'est
de toute façon déjà un sujet c'est à
dire que on voit bien que il donne de
l'eau au moulin à ce qu'il laisse
entendre aujourd'hui qu' il y aurait des
connivences qui aura été sont pas des
connivences puisque la gauche a toujours
été opposé à l'extrême droite moi j'ai
entendu ce qu'a dit stanislas guérini où
il disait qu'un mur était tombé puisque
le ps et le rassemblement national aller
manifester ensemble
ça n'a aucun sens c'est un moyen pour
lui d'essayer de stigmatiser le parti
socialiste est d'ailleurs les gens qui
ont manifesté hier c'est dangereux à mon
sens et puis je ne peux que rappeler
qu'une seule chose qu'une chose c'est
que les connivences où les
rapprochements je parle des faits je
parle pas de ceux qui enverrait le même
texto à la même personne en disant
joyeux noël plein de gens peuvent le
faire des militants frontistes comme moi
également ce n'est pas ce que fait pas
de moi quelqu'un d'extrême droite
par contre moi je note que toute une
série de réformes et d'amendements ces
derniers mois ont été votés quelquefois
avec l'appui du front national des monts
été porté par ce gouvernement je pense
notamment à la loi asile immigration ou
dans son article 5
les députés l'om sont allés chercher les
voix du front national pour faire passer
cet amendement ça me semble bien plus
grave
voilà mais tout ça moi m'embête parce
que en vous entendant tous à leur parler
des corps intermédiaires
j'avais andré me dire que j'avais envie
de dire que l'ancien monde avait du bon
et
quand
j'entends
ces petites phrases quand j'entends la
stratégie la tactique puisque ce même
pas de la stratégie la tactique
gouvernementale qui vise à essayer de
décrédibiliser la gauche en la mêlant au
front national tout ça moi m'inquiète
énormément je ne dis pas que ça
n'existait pas dans l'ancien monde mais
en tout cas c'est certainement quelque
chose qu'il faudrait dégager
du jeu politique en même temps hervé
nathan sur la retraite par exemple
retour dans la retraite à 60 ans sur le
rétablissement de la sf sur l'opposition
à la réforme actuelle c'est vrai que le
rassemblement national est sur une ligne
économique et social qui est pas si
éloigné que ça de la france insoumise
non non pas sur les sf mais bon c'est
vrai que sur c'est vrai qu'il ya des
poings liés dans le bloc dans le bloc
populaire qui est divisée qui est
représenté par deux l une l extrême
droite chainel à l'extrême gauche
il ya effectivement des il ya des
revendications communes des objectifs
économiques communs oui c'est mais ça
veut pas dire que c'est que que qu'il
faut ça veut pas dire qu'il faudrait y
voir l'amorcé d'un rapprochement par
exemple je pense qu'on serait une très
grosse erreur parce que je pense que les
deux publics sont sont pas
interchangeables sans nous ayons la même
façon qu'on n'a finalement c'est pas là
le rapport entre une partie de
l'électorat de droite et le parti d'être
aura du front national sont décédés soit
là si on n'est pas en italie hockey
n'est pas encore a lieu à des situations
italiennes et pendant tout ce qu'on sait
des sondages cette étude sur ces deux
publics
on sait que leurs valeurs sont
différentes même si on regarde ce qui a
fait le monsieur cohen récemment celle
là fait une étude sur les valeurs de
respectives des électeurs du front
national et c'est de la france a
soumises s'est cassé c'est à l'opposé
alors lui j'ai vu que il en train de
revenir dessus en disant mais j'ai fait
l'ironie ou c'était du deuxième degré
bon c'est vrai qu'on peut lui reprocher
d'avoir quand même dans son camp je
pense qu'on leur prochain il embête et
bien parce que on entend dire qu'elle se
rapproche d'un humanisme pour
dédiaboliser un parti politique on a
diabolisé pendant des années des années
c'est ya rien de mieux que personne
n'aurait pu imaginer de trouver une
formule aussi belle pour sortir marine
le pen de son ghetto qui n'en est plus
un depuis bien longtemps mais comme son
ghetto imaginaire à gauche jacques
maritain dans son sens de la formule
j'ai fait une erreur maxime décalé je
disais que le fond le rationnel étaient
opposés au démantèlement de sf non je me
trompe vous disais sur lui et ses fils
sont pas la cause de l'isf
nous sommes fin
la france insoumise et pour le
rétablissement de la fff comme le parti
fils comme beaucoup de français en
l'occurrence de mémoire dans le
programme du front national il est
toujours lundi n'ont jamais été contre
10 20 pour les esprits à bon alors c'est
peut-être moi qui me trompe dans ce cas
là je retire ce que je viens de dire et
je donne la parole aux internautes ce
qu'ils se trompent pas en tout cas ils
considèrent qu'à ceux qui se considèrent
majoritairement que non une convergence
entre jean luc mélenchon et marine le
pen n'est pas possible c'est non à 67%
rollin nous dit les extrêmes sont deux
pôles à la fois si éloignées et si
proche vrai que c'est un peu dur en même
temps mais il ya beaucoup de vrai
là-dedans dupe je ne partage pas les
idées de monsieur mélenchon mais il est
honnête intellectuellement madame le pen
est une opportuniste qui jouent sur les
peurs
et puis si je considère qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de rapprochement sur le fond
entre ces deux parties et jean-michel
nous dit et c'est évidemment une
occasion d'entendre paolo levi là dessus
l'italie a déjà testé une coalition
extrême droite et extrême gauche et on a
vu le résultat
est-ce que ça ressemble un peu à ce qui
s'est passé en italie cette esquisse
d'un rapprochement possible
en mai michelle dans ce commentaire il a
tout dit voilà c'est ce que je
m'apprêtais à dire c'est pas de la
science fiction chez nous ça a été une
réalité une expérience de gouvernement
qui a duré presque un an une forme une
sorte de mélange sionisme représenté par
le mouvement 5 étoiles une sorte de deux
greffes entre les gilets jaunes et
mélenchon pour simplifier expliqué un
public français et de l'autre côté
matteo salvini l alter ego de marine le
pen en italie ils ont tenté cette
expérience complètement improbable qui a
duré ce qu'elle a duré un an et et avec
des résultats assez catastrophique pour
pour le pays donc c'est possible hélas
c'est pas de la science fiction mais
mais il y à un autre système aussi en
italie à notre système électoral je
pense que qu'en france c'est très
difficile que ça puisse se produire
et sur le fond sylvain trop parce que
vous pensez que les deux électorats sont
trop différents pour kylie
une convergence possible au-delà de ces
petits clins d'oeil conjoncturelle on
voit quand même une augmentation du
nombre d'électeurs de la france a
soumise par exemple aux européennes qui
seraient prêts à voter pour marine le
pen on l'a vu dans les tout derniers
sondages on n'est pas encore sûr du
massif mais ça commence à être sensibles
le problème pour jean luc mélenchon sait
que ça se fait dans ce sens là et pas
dans l'autre sens et que lui en termes
de connivence ou en tout cas en terme de
doute qu'il instille chez ses partisans
sur la sincérité de son combat contre le
rassemblement national ben ya déjà une
casserole et une grosse ceseda
présidentielle de 2017 ou vocaux lui
reprocher de ne pas appeler de refuser
même d'appeler à voter pour évaluer le
maquereau pour faire barrage
ils n'ont pas fait cette déclaration là
elle vient sur ce elle rajoute une
couche dans un registre déjà mélenchon
avait avait perdu des voix et perdu des
soutiens par son ambiguïté
donc pour lui c'est vraiment à un coût
très maladroit je comprends qu'il
chercha à faire marcher merci machine
arrière
lui aussi même si sur le fond on n'a pas
attendu sa déclaration pour remarquer
effectivement et les similitudes entre
les programmes économiques et même
sociaux de marine le pen et de jean luc
mélenchon rappelez-vous nicolas bay
lieutenant de marine le pen qui disait
au temps de la gloire de florian
philippot moi j'ai pas envie que le
programme du front national à l'époque
je crois encore ressemble à un tract du
parti communiste français
et j'ajoute pour terminer cette partie
des missions que charlotte darche qui
assurent le fact checking en direct de
tout ce qu'on est en train de se dire
mais pas du tout le dit que j'avais tort
mais partiellement en fait il ya débat
au sein du rassemblement national par
rapport à l'iace r il y en a qui sont
franchement contre l' isf comme thierry
mariani qui vient des républicains en
revanche marine le pen elle a critiqué
les modalités du démantèlement dsf par
emmanuel macron on va changer de parti
si vous le voulez bien pour nous
intéresser au modem un certain nombre de
responsables de ce mouvement politique
ont été mises en examen dans une